hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the mandalorian episode three people
worse off gotta give shouts out to Eric
over at nerd chronic for editing these
reaction highlights for us he's done
editing for people like akazake moths no
boobie trivia Schmo DAP has his own
podcast remember podcasts were found we
will have the full length reaction
stream along or the mandalorian over at
our patreon page and over our patreon we
do stream along for many shows like
agents of shield strangers thing season
3 Gotham Cobra Kai Season 2 haunting a
hill house season 1 and then there are
shows we do stream along for them but
also have the option for reaction
highlights like I see the highlights cut
up for the Mandalorian it's like this
for these shows as well
supernatural hunter hunter Code Geass
Death Note my hero academia movie
included attack on Titan Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood and one punch man
yes go over to our patreon page damn
last thing I'm gonna be going out of
town this coming weekend and I won't be
back until next Saturday the next
Mandalorian reaction will be a little
bit late so do subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
we got that Mandalorian reaction up
let's get into this
hey time that total baby yoga moves so
adorable the clients will eat the baby
don't be scared little guy or girl
gender-neutral he strikes or does it
gonna becomes chewy yeah I'm gonna want
to talk down at the Mandalore him the
Wiener go the spoils
you're so smart I know my well-worn
turns of phrase that somehow made it to
this galaxy was it worth it madam
was it I can reinforce my whole armor
[Music]
I think he's gonna shoot up the place no
he's just gonna leave we're never gonna
see baby over again that best car is
enough to make a handsome replacement
for your armor finding the Mandalorian
these trying times is much difficult
than finding the steel ah but less
difficult than finding a baby Odin
werner herzog is like so passionate when
he speaks this would be in order for
your station I must warn you it will
draw many oh yeah like these three four
four six eight eight limit these are the
spoils of the great purge our world was
shattered by the Empire with whom this
tower chairs tables oh no no never
this is the way
the way this is the way she brushes
teeth always I have spoken this once a
non-believer but I think I'm gonna
become a part of the Mandalore culture
now yeah that's right you should get
yourself a helmet never take it off
I think Mandalore is a made for the best
reactions yes well
it's really triggers is past huh mmm
little Pedro Pascal
[Music]
[Music]
can't handle these grief fences haha
some precious cargo I just got turned
down from that guy
damn damn dude yeah of shiny he is now
it's gonna be reflecting everything now
how can I show my gratitude to my most
valuable partner I want my next job you
hunters like to keep busy right these
are all far away that's the best of the
lot a nobleman's son skipped bail mr.
Farnum ooh looks like you're headed to
the ocean dunes of karma son BAM any
idea what they're gonna do with it what
the assets a kid enjoy your reward
[Laughter]
by the time you come out of hyperdrive
you will have forgotten it's reminds me
of the Oracle matrix yeah I think it's
just cuz that last line which I believe
the Oracle said said number 4d he'll
leave sir he's gonna make him cookies oh
yeah big old softie oh damn he's doing
it Honus doing it haha dude
tough [ __ ] I love this music is good oh
babe it's like the best music of all the
TV right now now these guys know how to
shoot man he's in trouble
so do I love it this became like a
slasher movie for stormtroopers oh nice
that's the best stormtrooper and all the
Star Wars he's trying to hurt the child
I was trying to clearly try to save the
kid well kidnap a scientist guy wahwee
Batman him and the heavy armor - oh yeah
[Laughter]
hey men every stormtrooper thinks
they're gonna be the one to make a
difference
whoa-oh right through my man's office
what's up your sleeve mando Iron Man
yeah oh no there's a bounty out on John
Luke's head that's right
excommunication I have to go to a high
table to sort this no you're my best
friend the only person I should know
conversation
you put the bounty down and perhaps I'll
let you pass the kids come with me if
you truly care about the kid then you
put it on the speeder I love it we'll
discuss turn so Western standoff
come on man don't shoot your way out
mm-hmm that's what we all want to see
Harris doing this all while holding the
baby yeah
friggin roids listen Amanda he has
oh hell yeah Oh Carl grief
disintegration we killed you and we
strip your body for pucks
I've feeling someone's gonna come and
help him but I don't know who
[Music]
team manda Mandalore's haha Sam's all
here great excuse for all in the surface
together it's supposed to one at a time
at its best action is always our were
seriously get out of here oh it's got
his people
[Music]
come on man I wanted to come to this oh
how boys just a shoulder shot I know
ah
what are the odds was good now
[Laughter]
it's okay rody yeah season two Oh buddy
hmm
that was fantastic into the unknown
fantastic you know they're really
pulling off something that might sound
like really impossible to do on paper
you don't see this guy's face he's
writing a mass the whole time mm-hmm and
somehow the audience has to connect with
them yeah and it literally looks like me
to episodes I know I'm one big save the
cat moment this is really impressive
just like what they do with the bottle
there's like a mm-hmm that's how a
little bit more about it after food that
moment when he's on the on the droid
truck and he's just looking at the baby
like there's a lot you gotta do with
like camera angles and music and town
editing to really make this all
communicate it's like more than just
what petrol Pascal can do but it's it's
so impressive how he like I was getting
a little misty-eyed you're just like
looking at the baby no no like man I
don't know how this [ __ ] sure how it
shows doing it but they're doing it oh
all right I mean I'm in love with this
show pretty incredible stuff man weird I
was talking about it over the credits
and just in case it's not in the
reaction portion I'll just say it right
now I think what they've been able to do
with making us connect with this
character the Mandalorian character is a
really difficult thing to accomplish the
closest thing I can recall at least in a
movie of doing that is something like V
for Vendetta with a Hugo Weaving
behind the mask but in that one it's
like he's interactive natalie portman
the whole time now my Portman's more
with like the main character and he's
also a very expression it's character
yeah though he's got a mask on he speaks
a lot and he has a lot of intonation
yeah and then we got this Mandalorian
character who's stoic reserved not the
most expression it obviously obviously
somehow with all the proper use of
editing music direction with its camera
angles like seriously two shots that I
just keep thinking about it's a
difficult feat for someone like Petra
pascal's especially to do this what he's
in his ship and he's about to take off
and then he notices the ball is missing
that little moment it was so well done
in a visual storytelling sense to get
you to realize like he really cares
about this kid baby Yoda characters we
call them and it is a heat according to
the doctor into the doctor pronoun heat
so it's definitely Yoda
it's definitely Yoda Yoda and may go to
hell that reincarnated definitely we are
joke okay but no we know that at least
baby yo does he we know that they want
to extract something from the child we
don't really know what it is necessarily
if the child might survive the
extraction because cuz really what child
would know what's happened what would
you bounty a child and then be like
we're gonna extract something and this
kid's gonna be fine well with the stakes
be if the child was gonna be fine anyway
yeah yeah with like looking at the ball
and then gonna go rescue the baby I just
love that it's the whole sequence but
more than on the truck and he's just
looking at the baby like the way it's
cutting back and forth when the baby
slowly opening its eyes I was getting a
little misty I dislike how much who
really cares about this kid and I think
they're doing a really good job at
teasing mandos backstory to of being a
foundling it seems like anytime he gets
enough in Ann Arbor he's just gonna
flashback yeah just brings him back to
his roots the loss of his parents and
what I gather with the witness the show
so I don't know if we're gonna get some
full-blown episode where we just see the
whole backstory it's like it's a little
bit of that flashback in the first
episode that we saw a little bit more of
the same flashback in this episode
imagine that as the show keeps going
we'll just keep seeing that play out
which is a smart way to get us invested
in the core memory of this character but
it also makes sense so much of why he
cares so much about baby yoga yeah yeah
well next funny cause like the eye you
think about his origin when they're
showing you the flashbacks but I thought
of it a lot during that actual fight
because the thing they're always cutting
back to is yeah you know sort of a
massacre that's happening and so to have
him trying to protect a child being in
the same position from the opposite side
I thought was a nice kind of
undercurrent to that satellite and then
when you know his people show up at the
end you're expecting something to show
up and save him but yeah I had kind of
forgotten too and I think that was a
nice thing about the conflict having
them all sort of be against him in that
moment where he goes in with the best
car steel and is getting his upgrades
done I thought that was kind of an
interesting way to at least throw you
off that sense so that when they drive
back in it is sort of a surprise and I
wonder if maybe that's gonna be one of
the bigger arcs of the series is sort of
figuring out a new place for them to
roost because it doesn't seem like this
place is gonna be the place we're gonna
go back to our foundry now y'all play
cool up here all the Mandalore's all
came up to help I didn't see the armorer
there I mean armor is like almost Dave
huh well you know I'm me I'll be back
right maybe the armor is important maybe
not every Mandalorian has those skills
maybe she's got to stick around and make
sure that there's somebody to keep on
keepin on with the armor and the weapons
I don't know you can't just abandon your
post but if all the Mandalore's are off
you know now they're all kind of oh I
mean if you didn't move she's gonna move
but just in that fight I get it but yeah
I imagine though maybe in the next
episode if the armor did stated they're
probably gonna interrogate her but no
you bring up a good point because I
think what this show does an exceptional
job at and I really respect it for
committing as much to visual
storytelling without being expositional
about things cuz yeah like they could
have easily done in that battle sequence
keep cutting back to the past you know
but they didn't it's like they just
trust the audience we'll pick up on that
resonance there and I think it's
attention to detail on the Mandalore's
at the end of the day sticking together
in this situation like they have their
disagree ensues with our main character
but the end of the day you know it's
like we gotta go oh yeah you got it yeah
I'm out we gotta stick together and I
think I think that's actually like quite
beautiful it was more than just some
Easter egg what they are doing is
serving to flush out the world more and
more I'm not familiar with what this
great purges that they're talking about
to be totally transparent if you guys
want a chair go ahead please would love
to know as I don't know if that's
already been covered in other things
yeah but just to see them address that
and then put it aside and have that
whole thing about like this bisque or
steel is kind of a dubious origin given
our is memory with everything even
though yeah there is definitely conflict
I would imagine that might come back out
of that I did like that in the end they
have their unity as a people you know
and that seems to outweigh the stickier
details of the past and yeah politics
that come with this and I mean in that
moment where he's getting the crap for
the steal I'm also like you guys are all
kind of bounty hunters that he's not the
only one even though he has a ton of it
right now sure a church er and even just
the little thing to where he wants to
leave some of the rest of it for the
foundlings it's like little things like
that help you realize that underneath
that badass exterior that core memory is
very important in whatever way to him
but we got to talk about the badass
stuff yeah the way this show
successfully pulled off the tension is
wonderful because this might not be the
most hyper choreographed action we've
ever seen a lot of it just feels like
very traditional action set-pieces but
dumb with Star Wars fashion right down
to getting in the car or the truck where
the droid man's it points the code of
Detroit Drive it feels very traditional
holding the baby feels kind of like the
hard-boiled John Woo chow yun-fat action
movie but I love the way they do that
where it starts off as a stealth mission
to have the whole whistling birds set up
that feels like it would probably come
in to a later episode then use it this
episode
and we didn't exactly know what what it
was but then you see it coming to play
that was really cool
definitely felt like an Ironman moment
yeah and then it goes into Western
standoff kind of this John wick
excommunicate or thing you do think that
like it's just gonna be one person that
shows up and then it really does earn
that final moment and allures showing of
it helping to save the day I guess this
is like the real plot of the show or at
least in this season is that the
Mandalorian and the mandos are all gonna
be on the run we got to find out the
mystery behind this baby Yoda character
and I am just hooked into this I really
credit this show on knowing how to do
build up knowing how to give just enough
information to implore you don't end
every episode with what you get a little
bit more here and there but what they've
really been focusing on is establishing
what kind of man is the Mandalorian make
you know that's what it seems like these
specific episodes have primarily been
doing to get us hooked into this
character which is the hardest task for
a character who have no facial
expressions to go off not a lot of
dialogue to go off and they're doing it
I think this is this is exceptional yeah
it speaks to when you use the
fundamentals of storytelling and visual
storytelling to your best advantage you
know and also yeah that was a really
nice natural build up of that action
because just perfectly structured out in
the sense that it would it starts as a
sneak and then it turns into this big
mess that's right I love that I guess is
that each time he starts into something
that he's outmatched on it's not like he
is a superhero there is always something
that he has to rely on or there are
other people or there are circumstances
you know you really got to watch him
figure these situations out I love that
he is not just all invincible it's like
even though you kind of can assume what
this episode's gonna do in terms of
plotting like yeah you know he's
probably not gonna let the kid go and
stuff like that I think it makes up for
some elements that may be predictable in
that sense by sheer excellence in
execution and
attention to those details that make
this gradual story feel very rich and
worthwhile and we're herzog as this
client character speaks with such a
voice of philosophy and passion it is
like I get why they cast workers and
then Carl Weathers
you got to see so much more layers to
his character this time around a little
bit more of that Carl Weathers that I'm
more familiar with some that showmanship
like when mando walks in his best car I
got for it that's the Carl Weathers I
know and love ya but even that trope of
he got shot but then the the steel was
right there to protect him doesn't well
handled it's all hand and it wasn't just
of course they show in the earlier shot
when he pulls it out he's saying
something I'm rich - yeah it puts it
back right there so I did establish that
it's not unexpected and they didn't cue
the audience in on that and it makes you
wonder did mando see and remember that
yeah it issued intentionally yeah
attentionally in an area where it
wouldn't do damage yeah cuz I don't
think he wanted to kill him as I
imagined the man is a little bit
conflicted about his choice here because
this is breaking you know the rules the
guidelines guideline it's the natural
rules that he abides by - and he almost
doesn't you know he almost just goes out
on another bounty and tries to forget
about it but then also speaking of Star
Wars lore because this is after Return
of the Jedi before force awakens a
knowledge New Republic it's joke take a
stab at the new jewelry but no but my
point with that is in terms of breaking
the rules and growing adapting
developing transitioning bringing up the
New Republic in this episode I thought
was a good thing because this is the
mando like not just our main character
it seems like the Mandalore's all
transitioning to a new kind of order
this is the way this is - hey no man the
quotes I have spoken I have spoken is
the way
there's gonna be so many new t-shirts
for us to buy a different quote for a
better start getting ready yeah get
those tattoos going I want to get one
hand this is the way in one hand I have
spend a lot more fingers for this I love
that name grief carga because I feel
like Carl Weathers based his whole
character off of that name yeah the
figures always has these tree fences
cargo presence my cargo
yeah yeah I want to know who sits around
like there's got to be a Star Wars name
generator' there's got to be a guy who
sits around whose job it is to come up
with Star Wars names because they're
always so cool but they're always like
quintessentially Star Wars real quick to
the other moment that I love like these
little nuggets to give you good
character insight when he is talking
with the armor exactly something from
the armor because oh he's not taking the
Signet of the one horn because he didn't
defeat it in cause he got help from his
enemy and the enemy did not know that
that was his enemy at the time and the
way he delivers that line you could feel
the sense of disappointment her
reluctance is it doesn't ring a
hundred-percent enemy yeah yeah there's
like a hint of regret it's like a weird
thing to say about a baby
yes helped you defeat a giant you know
land creature like trying to call it as
enemy when he doesn't feel like it
really is so so good so good
alright guys well thanks for watching
you could join us at patron out where we
got our full-length stream along is over
there make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell for whatever we
got a new video up and especially the
Mandalorian one thank you so much this
is the way
all right so we have tried to get this
up on YouTube without it getting blocked
what we're gonna do is what we've seen
other reaction channels do in certain
cases like this there's a Vimeo link in
the description box to just watch the
reaction but please do come back and
watch the review of the episode when
you're done watching the reaction it
would really help us out and it would be
great incentive to keep going with these
reactions as well so thank you guys